on en reparle avec Armelle charrier
bonjour Armel le quotidien de la
population
ukrainienne est donc de plus en plus
compliquée oui c'est un quotidien qu'on
connu il faut juste faire un parallèle
toutes les populations qui sont souvent
en guerre on avait la même problématique
en Syrie on avait la même problématique
en Irak on avait la même problématique à
Sarajevo pendant les guerres de Bosnie
par exemple c'est à dire de prendre la
population civile en otage en touchant
effectivement par l'électricité et l'eau
quand vous touchez l'électricité
concrètement ça veut dire quoi c'est
juste pas que vous n'ayez plus
l'électricité dans votre appartement
c'est que vous n'avez plus le chauffage
dans des régions où il peut faire les
hivers on peut faire moins 20 - 30 mais
vous n'avez pas aussi plus d'eau parce
que l'eau en fait quand elle monte dans
les étages elle monte par les pompes
électriques donc si vous n'avez plus
d'électricité vous n'avez plus d'eau
vous n'avez plus d'internet donc on
parle d'une -30% des billes internet en
ce moment en Ukraine les Ukrainiens sont
servent beaucoup parce que ça leur
permet d'avoir des systèmes d'alerte
parce que cela permet de mettre des
vidéos en ligne et être communiquer avec
avec leurs proches et puis ensuite quand
vous sortez vous avez faire les courses
et bien vous avez besoin d'un champ
liquide et là vous ne pouvez plus
retirer parce que aujourd'hui tous les
guichets de bancaires sont rompus donc
il y a eu des courses qui ont été faites
en urgence avec des bougies avec tout ce
genre de choses mais si vous n'avez pas
pensé à mettre de l'argent liquide de
côté si vous n'avez pas des vêtements
chauds si ceci c'est extrêmement
difficile à tenir et ça fait ça fait
maintenant un mois que cette campagne
intense de bombardement des sites
énergétiques se poursuivent oui et on
voit que c'est une stratégie militaire
en fait de la part de la Russie parce
que quand on tape pendant un an un mois
comme le fait la Russie d'une part à y
consacre des missiles et les consacre
des drones c'est à dire que là on a
encore et que elle sait qu'elle va
toucher en fait aussi bien le moral de
la population mais derrière vous avez
aussi des ruptures j'allais dire qui
sont stratégiques parce que vous allez
toucher avec l'électricité les usines
d'armement qui du coup ne peuvent plus
produire il y en a en Ukraine vous allez
toucher les réseaux ferrés par exemple
et puis vous allez toucher aussi tout un
système d'acheminement d'information sur
le est là où les combattants sont en
train justement de se confronter aux
Russes parce que derrière ils ont des
ordres qui dépendent de Kiev donc si
vous avez des problèmes de téléphonie et
bien dans ces cas-là il y avait un
cheminement qui est moindre si vous
devez leur apporter de l'armement et
bien à partir du moment donné où vous
avez pas forcément les mêmes routes les
mêmes chemins de fer vous n'avez pas la
même chose et puis si vous ne leur
apportez pas de la restauration pareil
vous touchez aussi le moral des
combattants dernier point quand c'est
fait pendant un mois avec autant
d'intensité c'est que vous savez que
derrière les lignes évidemment les
lignes à haute tension les Ukrainiens
les reconstruisent évidemment on va
l'arrache humide mais en attendant quand
c'est au quotidien et bien à un moment
donné soit vous avez pu les outils soit
vous avez plus les tronçons qu'il
nécessitent et les lignes elles aussi
elles baisent en tension merci beaucoup
Armelle pour cet éclairage sur la
situation